Пляшка горілки і дві пачки цигарок.
Цей набір вже став символом українсько-польського кордону.
Особливо тут, на території Польщі відразу
за пішохідним пунктом пропуску "Шегині-Медика".
Цих українців називають "човники" або "піджаки".
Вони ходять туди-сюди через кордон
і намагаються заробити на різниці в ціні на алкоголь і тютюн.
-Норма на добу.
-Два блоки?
-Дві пачки!
-Дві пачки?
-Дві маленьких.
Блок цигарок на територію ЄС можна провозити,
коли перетинаєш кордон літаком,
а в пішому порядку одній людині дозволяється пронести
тільки дві пачки цигарок і пляшку горілки.
Такі митні правила.
Висить великий плакат українською та польською:
"Запам'ятай! Заборона торгівлі підакцизними товарами!"
Але це нікого не зупиняє.
Люди намагаються хоч щось заробити.
10 злотих, але за 8 віддаю!
Продавши пляшку горілки і дві пачки цигарок, можна заробити приблизно 100 гривень.
Пенсія у цих жінок - 1760 гривень на місяць,
і для них це важлива прибавка до пенсії.
Щойно пощастило ще одному пенсіонеру.
Під'їхала машина і він перепродав свої дві пачки цигарок.
Марія не хоче, щоб показували її обличчя.
Ходить через кордон двічі на тиждень.
У мене чоловік має пенсію,
йому зробили операцію - два клапани на серці поміняли,
то він має півтори тисячі гривень пенсію.
На тисячу гривень я купую ліки.
495 гривень лишається.
Тому й доводиться "човночити" туди-сюди.
Ще одна схема заробітку на кордоні -
дроблення партій товару, що завозиться в Україну з країн ЄС.
На одну людину можна без мита провезти товар на 500 євро
і вагою до 50 кілограмів.
Дрібні бізнесмени набирають повну машину чи автобус пенсіонерів
і оформлюють на них телевізори або іншу електроніку.
За одну ходку "бабуся-транспортер" отримує
200-300 гривень, іноді більше.
Правда, щодня так уже не "почовникуєш".
Згідно із законом, дозволяється провозити такий товар
лише раз на три дні, при цьому аж цілу добу
потрібно бути не на території України.
Роман теж змушений займатися цим час від часу.
Краще, ніж сидіти вдома.
Якщо немає роботи, то іншого виходу немає.
Я зоотехнік. Але у Львівській області
для цієї професії нема роботи.
Львівська область. Містечко Мостиська на кордоні з Польщею.
Порожній парк біля церкви. Забиті вікна.
На вулиці лише літні люди.
Майже вся молодь виїхала на заробітки за кордон.
Мер бідкається: раніше було 4 бригади
по 5-6 осіб плитку класти, а тепер лише два робочих залишилося.
Незабаром не буде кому вулиці прибирати і за прилавком стояти.
Ми на самому кордоні,
і в нас знайти десь працівницю
для точок громадського харчування, ресторанів, кафе,
в магазини - сьогодні дуже велика буде проблема,
а на наступний рік може бути ще більша.
Магазин поруч з офісом мера.
Продавчиня в магазині іронізує: бачите, за касою вже
літні в окулярах стоять. Молоді немає. Всі за кордоном.
Є такі що мають по тижню там,
а на суботу-неділю вдома, є що місяць.
Хто яку роботу має.
Ціни в них на все такі, як у нас,
але вони більше заробляють.
Кажуть: ми собі можемо і за квартиру заплатити, і щось собі відкласти.
А це дорога між українськими пропускними пунктами Шегині та Краковцем.
Між ними лише 35 кілометрів,
але їхати понад годину по таких вибоїнах.
Дорогу так і не можуть до кінця доремовнтувати вже багато років.
У нормальному стані лише окремі ділянки.
Але саме ця дорога дуже важлива для тих, хто перетинає кордон.
Якщо на одному з пропускних пунктів черги, вони могли б швидко переїхати до іншого.
На стовпах уздовж дороги - оголошення
з рекламою роботи в Польщі.
-Отой ліс - то наш кордон. Бачиш?
Наше до лісу, а то вже поляки.
- Як життя тут?
-Якби не Польща, то ми б поздихали.
-Як, як? Не розчув.
- Кажу, якби не Польща… Нас Польща рятує.
Нікого вдома нема - всі в Польщі.
У польському поїзді з Перемишля до Кракова майже в кожному вагоні
чути українську мову. Українці їдуть на роботу.
Руслан, як правило, два місяці працює в Польщі, потім тиждень-два вдома.
Каже: в районі, де він живе, робота є,
але зарплата лише 3-5 тисяч гривень на місяць.
Родину за ці гроші не прогодувати.
Тому й доводиться їздити в Польщу.
Працюєш з 7 ранку до 7-8 вечора в полі,
а якщо сезон починається, полуниця, то і до 10-12 ночі в полі можеш бути.
Зараз їдемо садити дерева.
То буде 10 годин робочих.
А неділя вихідна.
Треба пахати добре, щоб заробити тисячу доларів на місяць.
У Руслана вже є робоча віза, але поляки, незважаючи на загрозу штрафів
і рейди поліції, беруть на роботу навіть українців, які в’їхали в Польщу
по "безвізу", що не дає права на працевлаштування.
Беруть з "безвізом" на будь-яку роботу.
Тільки щоб ніде ти не вештався, щоб тебе не бачила поліція.
Поляки роз’їхалися.
Фінляндія, Норвегія. Швеція. Там, де добрі заробітки.
Для них тут недобрі гроші.
Тут у них працюють тільки ті, хто хочуть випити і нікуди не хочуть їхати працювати.
А молодь у них масово виїжджає так само.
Безвізовий режим між Україною та країнами ЄС діє вже майже два роки.
Якщо раніше багато людей перетинали кордон
за картками малого прикордонного руху,
то тепер - за біометричними паспортами
і не лише з прикордонних територій.
Україна та Польща мають 536 кілометрів спільного кордону,
велика частина якого - майже 300 кілометрів - у Львівській області.
Тут 6 прикордонних пунктів пропуску.
Тобто приблизно кожні 50 кілометрів.
Цікаво, що між Німеччиною і Польщею до того, як Варшава вступила в ЄС,
пропускні пункти були кожні 25 кілометрів.
Тож, Україні й Польщі потрібно рівно вдвічі більше переходів,
щоб відповідати євростандартам
і щоб люди могли швидко і зручно перетинати кордон,
вважає начальник Львівської митниці.
Сьомий пункт пропуску вже в планах.
У 2019 році, згідно з інформацією
наших польських колег,
планується завершення проектування пункту Нижанковичі-Мальговіце.
А щодо реконструкції існуючих пунктів пропуску,
вже проведені тендерні закупівлі,
тобто укладені договори, і ми очікуємо виділення коштів,
польського кредиту для фінансування цих робіт.
Черги з автомобілів у пунктах перетину кордону стали значно меншими -
бо стало менше так званих "євроблях".
Це автомобілі з іноземною реєстрацією, найчастіше - з польською або литовською.
Щоб не платити за розмитнення, власники постійно їздили на них
у режимі "тимчасового ввезення".
Для цього потрібно було регулярно перетинати кордон,
і це створювало затори в пунктах пропуску.
За неофіційною статистикою, таких машин
в Україну завезли понад два мільйони.
Наприкінці минулого року вступили в дію закони,
спрямовані на легалізацію "євроблях" ,
і ця проблема на кордоні поволі зникає.
Можна бачити, які саме автомобілі нині перетинають кордон,
і машин з громадянами України на так званих "євробляхах"
майже немає. Лише окремі випадки.
А от від контрабанди нікуди не дітися.
У польських митників в коридорі - своєрідний музей.
Тут і шкура ведмедя, й опудала птахів, корали,
банки з чорною ікрою. Все це намагалися нелегально провезти
через кордон, але попалися. Ось недавній улов - шкура вовка.
А це вже склади вилучених товарів українськими митниками.
Тут усе зберігається до рішення суду.
Упаковки памперсів, ящики з консервованим горошком та різний інший товар.
Через кордон дозволяється перевозити 2 кілограми одного виду
продуктів харчування на одну особу. Тож, ця капуста вже контрабандна.
Її власнику, швидше за все, доведеться сплатити штраф 1700 гривень,
а сама капуста підлягає знищенню.
Якщо немає документів, що підтверджують безпеку і якість,
товари і продукти утилізують. А якщо є - то продають.
Виручені кошти перераховуються до держбюджету.
Один з головних контрабандних товарів - цигарки.
Це запасне колесо служило схованкою для тютюнових виробів.
Цигарки для того, щоб їх було важче виявити,
навіть замотують спеціальною чорною "ізолєнтою", скочем.
Щоб коли ти дивишся, просвічуєш
якісь схованки, щоб вони не падали у вічі.
Тобто так її зразу видно,  коли ти просвічуєш,
і так не побачиш. Треба бути уважним.
Цигарки після ухвалення судом рішення про конфіскацію не продають, а спалюють.
Алкоголь також не виставляють на продаж, а зливають у каналізацію.
На українській території поблизу кордону можна побачити
ось такі магазини-склади.
Тут, як правило, і купують цигарки та горілку для перепродажу в Польщі.
Коли немає роботи або низькі зарплати і пенсії,
принцип "купив-продав" - єдина можливість заробити.
Щоправда, вже з’явилися оголошення про роботу не лише в Польщі, а й в Україні.
. Навіть навчають безкоштовно і возять на підприємство.
Людей у прикордонних районах потрібно повертати до традицій,
щоб вони займалися землею і тваринництвом,
вважає голова громадської організації
"Асоціація платників податків України" у Львівській області Лілія Долінська.
Якби на прикордонних зонах створити
пункти заготівель того ж молока,
іншої сільськогосподарської продукції -
це настільки важливо було б для
знищення проблеми "човників".
Потрібна державна програма розвитку індивідуальних фермерських господарств
і дешеві кредити на відкриття бізнесу, вважають експерти.
Тоді в прикордонні райони повернеться молодь.
Поки що ж більше можливостей по той бік кордону.
Це найбільший польський торговельно-складський комплекс
на кордоні ЄС і України. Саме тут, як правило, скуповуються українці.
Скрізь червоні бірки з написом "суперціна".
Крім торгівлі, тут збираються налагодити й виробництво.
Будемо робити паперові рушники.
Для цього тут є дешева робоча сила і багато українців,
які шукають роботу недалеко від дому.
Недалеко від цього торговельного центру -
могила композитора, автора музики державного гімну України Михайла Вербицького.
Коли тут відбуваються пам’ятні заходи, місцеві поляки охоче сприяють цьому.
Пригощають тістечками та кавою,
організовують парковки для тих, хто приїжджає на урочистості.
А от на цій парковці поруч із кордоном українцям не дуже раді.
Тут повісили фото молодих людей,
які декілька років тому сфотографувалися на фоні червоно-чорного прапора УПА.
За це їм заборонили в’їзд на парковку.
Той прапор, який там висить, показує, що це Польща.
Бо вони казали, що вони в себе вдома.
Я відповідаю: поводьтеся нормально, коли приїжджаєте до ЄС.
Але вони на це не зважають. Кажуть: пам’ятай, ляше, по Віслу наше.
Кордон об’єднує українців і поляків, але чимало сторінок історії розділяє їх.
На травмах минулого спекулюють деякі політики з обох країн.
За словами представниці української меншини
у прикордонному Перемишлі Тетяни Наконечної,
у 90-ті та на початку 2000-двотисячних років
стосунки між українцями та поляками були більш-менш нормальні,
а в останні роки національне питання штучно роздмухується.
Я не боюся того, що
в передвиборній кампанії у Польщі,
коли були вибори президента, скажімо, чи влади міста,
вживали слово українець як найбільше прокляття.
цього не боюся. Я боюся звичайних людей,
які - просто для прикладу -
в магазині до українця говорять вже не пан, а кажуть на ти.
Або коли ми робимо якийсь концерт, якусь подію,
вони стають з гаслами також "Волинь - помстити" не знати чому.
Я боюся реакції звичайних поляків найбільше.
Декілька років тому на 70-ту річницю етнічних чисток з обох сторін -
Волинської трагедії - у польському місті Радимно
провели реконструкцію знищення українцями польського села.
Подібні акції не сприяють примиренню, вважають у багатьох інших прикордонних містечках
і закликають залишити історію історикам і рухатися вперед.
Були образи взаємні, я так вважаю.
І такі образи треба простити.
І найбільше ми бачимо, хто прощає образи - це молодь.
Шкільна молодь. Вони між собою знаходять порозуміння
буквально за декілька хвилин.
А, на жаль, серед старшого населення залишилися люди,
які мають образи сімейні, родинні
і, можливо, через те їх болить,
але це власна позиція кожного громадянина - як України, так і Польщі.
Вчителька Наталія та лікар Олег Корпани
вже 12 років живуть у Польщі.
Кажуть: коли переїхали, не було такого
зверхнього ставлення до українців, як тепер.
Особисто ми, наша родина, ми того не відчуваємо.
З іншого боку, можна десь почути, що ставляться,
як до другосортних,
як Ви кажете,
але ми особисто на собі того не відчули.
Повертатися назад в Україну не збираються.
Вони вже громадяни Польщі.
Тут народилася їхня донька Марта.
-То хто ти: українка чи полька? Як правильно?
-Одна і друга.
-А більше себе ким відчуваєш?
-Українкою.
Чим далі від кордону - тим менше національних непорозумінь.
Приміром, у Кракові. У центрі міста ресторан української кухні.
Сюди залюбки приходять і місцеві поляки, і туристи.
Борщ єднає усіх.